foreign
is with us in Chicago hi Terry welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi John hey what's up
Yeah so basically I'm a business owner
with irregular income I am married but I
cannot unfortunately get my husband to
combine these finances
I'm aware that we do need to work
together and counseling is definitely
crucial but at this point I'm 52. and I
need to go ahead and do this on my own
I've done it before
um I did something foolish I started uh
using my credit cards again
um basically I relocated my business and
when I relocated my business I think I
kind of just kind of went over spending
um for the business and now uh the
location that I am that I'm at now we
are
um I think you know we're in the June
July so usually the summer months are
really slow but I didn't think that the
relocation it will be Terry what's your
question so the question is because I
need to go ahead and start doing this on
my own
um I definitely have a lot of debt and I
have done baby step number one and
number three multiple times
um but I'm just trying to figure out
what is the best way to go about paying
off my debt
um so that's pretty much what it is
um yeah
how long you've been married
well hey we just 10 years
why is it he doesn't want to combine
finances you know what he's he's kind of
I don't know he's
and I can't really go off into all of
the details if I did everybody would
know who I am however
um at this point you know it's just kind
of like he just does not want to uh
combine finances he's content with just
you know giving his portion of what's uh
what we're going to pay for the home
um so I do carry part of what the
responsibility is in the home in terms
of the utilities I'm sorry I can't I
can't go along with this I don't I don't
I agree I'm I'm not going to participate
in this insanity I got I agree I agree
this is unhealthy and you know it's
unhealthy and you refuse to deal with it
why oh I'm definitely trying to deal
with it no you're not trying to deal
with it you're trying to work around it
um short of
you know we need to we need to get to
the bottom I know I I don't I can't
really tell you everything but at the
end of the day I'm I'm feeling stuck
um and I don't want to feel stuck I feel
like I want to do this with him but I
know I'm gonna have to just do it on my
own for my on my portion
um so here's the thing you
let's take that track you know how you
know what to do you put your debts in in
order smallest to largest and you pay
them off
but you've got a so that the math
problem is simple you're too smart you
know that I say I think you're asking
Dave and I a different question
um no uh what it is I don't the amount
of money that I have saved uh is not
equal to it's not equal to what I need
to pay things off
um but here's the thing you've got two
big messes I don't it I think you're
talking around the bush about your
business I don't think your business is
is as successful as you thought it was
going to be
and I think you have to make some hard
some hard choices about your business
and your marriage is at that 10-year
Mark and there's a seven to ten year
window when people start to open their
eyes and they exhale and they realize
this is the way this is gonna be
and we need to have some hard
conversations about what comes next or
we have to make peace with this is the
way this is but Dave said it right
you're you are accepting in rhetoric you
are not accepting this in reality
because reality says I'm going to turn
on all the lights I'm gonna stop the
music and I'm gonna tell my significant
other the the marriage we've built thus
far ends today will you build something
new with me
and they call that vulnerability and
it's got vulnerability's got this great
um cachet about it and it's wonderful
and great except that vulnerability
means somebody may hurt you and he may
look at you and say I will not be a part
of a marriage where I'm going to be all
in with you and you have to deal with
that reality and you're not
that's a scary place to be
but that's the truth of the matter
and you and I'm not saying you got to
end your marriage you may have to say
okay fine I'm on my own inside my own
house that's what she is saying and if
that's if you've gone yeah or she's
acquiesced I mean she gave up
and says I want to go work this by
myself and the problem is your
probability of Building Wealth when your
spouse is not participating is very low
it's hard you might clear out you might
clear out the debt but the number of
times that we interviewed millionaires
ten thousand one hundred sixty seven of
them that they said I did this while
dragging my spouse kicking and screaming
all the way and became a millionaire
anyway when they didn't participate they
didn't help I basically had a roommate
and a joint venture not a marriage
and the number of times that that
happened statistically in the data is
almost never I mean it's a it's way less
than five percent yeah and so what
you're asking to do is um statistically
improbable
a can it be done well good Lord yeah I'm
almost anything can be done but it's
just it's unhealthy because now what
we're saying is we're just going to put
our hands over our ears and go la la la
la la la la la la la and pretend like
this is not going on and we're going to
go on about our way and we're going to
try to be try to be wealthy anyway we're
gonna try to get out of debt and stay
out of debt anyway but something else is
going on here that y'all really need to
get the bottom of for the sake of your
marriage also for the sake of your
futures if you find so let's let's go to
the end let's if you find yourself in
your in the person you're married to
says I'm out I'm not doing this
I'm not recommending you then you run to
divorce court yes that's not the way to
go but then you're going to follow the
baby steps the way you follow the baby
steps and you're gonna have to create a
life where I may have to go get second
jobs I have to go get third jobs I may
have to figure this thing out and you
may have to go to counseling on your own
if the person just refuses to go with
you
um but my hope is that someone would see
your determination they would see the
path you're taking and see the light
that's coming on in your eyes and they'd
say hey I want to be a part of that I
know that's not true if you're married
to someone who struggles with addiction
if you're married to somebody who just
doesn't care someone's struggling with
certain kinds of mental I get all that
but at some point you either have to say
hey this is it we're going to have this
final conversation and if they won't do
it I mean they won't do it
um
yeah Dave sometimes it's throwing your
hands up and saying ah whatever it's not
worth it and sometimes I mean you're
just
I mean the old ball and chain is the old
ball and chain you're married to a guy
that just says I ain't I'm not getting
off the couch
um and then you got some hard choices to
make I guess yeah that's where you're
facing and so I'm just telling you that
in doing this in spite of your spouse
folks
um and everything's staying separate a
it's a lot harder and B your probability
is just not there uh and then what we're
dealing with is the money problems are
not a problem they're a symptom of your
relationship problems that's what's
going on and I I think it's important to
double click on that
um if somebody won't work with you your
biggest issue in your life is not your
debt that's what I'm trying to say your
biggest issue is you've got a marriage
that's that's sick and that is falling
apart and that is slowly killing both of
you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
again him's refusing to put your money
together is not a a philosophical stand
it's a relational spear through the
heart right he's throwing darts or
somebody who's uh in and you know
another thing Dave we we're saying I
don't trust you well I was gonna say it
may be that this is the third or fourth
time you've moved your business and gone
back on credit cards and he's saying hey
I'm not I'm not hitching my wagon you're
out of control I'm not trustworthy and
so maybe it's about you coming to the
table and saying hey I've been
struggling I haven't been right with
this stuff I'm willing to change will
you join me right and that's almost
always the best way to approach it but
um he may be watching you be a train
wreck over there and going I don't want
to ride on that thing I don't want to be
on that train that's right that's right
that may be the way you solve it but
anyway yeah that the thing is you need
to get up under this thing and solve
that part of it for the quality of life
that you have on going forward and uh
you know for your relationship to
prosper and then for your money to
prosper they very seldom are not
connected right these are not
compartmentalized departmentalized
things but you can set this over here
and pretend like this other isn't
happening they are woven together
inextricably you cannot get away from it
and so it's just it's tough so I hope
you can hope you can get to the bottom
of it Terry I hope you guys can find
some peace and uh find some you know
Unity at your place